don't you just hate it when your Paris
vacation is ruined by a bunch of falling
zombies or your creepy friend has
created his own zombie Orchestra look no
further than this week's episode of The
Walking Dead Daryl Dixon a show that
continues to surprise me in cool and
interesting ways in this video we'll be
taking a deep dive into the episode and
answering some of its biggest questions
like is Quinn really Lauren's father and
be sure to stick around till the end of
the video where I'll be going over the
season's trailers to see if we can find
any clues on where the story is headed
but before we get into it make sure to
like And subscribe every little bit
helps the channel out the episode begins
here in algae France if we take a look
at this map we can see just how far
Daryl has come from escaping the tanker
in the Gulf of Cadiz arriving ashore
near marsai and diverting from Father
John's original plan around vienne if
you remember back in episode 2 Isabelle
told Daryl they must take a longer path
to anje rather than go directly to Paris
because she knows a man who has a radio
there the redo at the Abbey was broken
and they need a new way to alert their
compatriots at the nest the name for
this secret base that will raise Laurel
that they're on their way so the gang
makes it to this abandoned theater where
we meet a man simply known as the
conductor he's part of the network known
as the union of Hope a group of
different face that believe humanity is
being tested unfortunately this guy is a
few baguettes sort of a picnic and has
used the parts from the radio to amplify
the speakers of his very own a personal
zombie Orchestra this was really messed
up but my personal favorite was the
heart player the song the conductor
plays is Maurice ravel's Bolero who in
the 1920s and 30s was considered
France's greatest living composer
meanwhile outside Sylvie prepares to
fight off an infected who is oddly
chained up to a dead body I really love
these choices made by the writers it
makes me wonder what on Earth did these
two do to get themselves chained up like
this escaping to Paris the gang passes a
famous building known as the pantheon
which has a large Banner reading Fourier
meaning flee interesting fact the school
last episode was named after a woman
named simonevale who just so happens to
be buried there according to Isabel most
of Paris is under the control of a woman
named Janae who runs an organization
called puvoir duvivor or power of Life
we've seen their markers all the way
back in episode 1 when Isabelle covers
it with her own poster and we saw Janae
order that this Daryl Dixon be captured
after he said Ablaze their tanker which
acted as some sort of research vessel
just how exactly Daryl got there and
escaped isn't yet known but the previous
hint that we'll find this out in a later
episode this episode also confirms that
Janae and her team are conducting some
sort of experiments on the undead I have
a sneaking suspicion these guys aren't
testing for a cure because if they are
they are failing miserably whatever
they've given this zombie seems to give
it super strength before it explodes
after 18 seconds which leads me to
believe they may be looking to create
some sort of weapon if Daryl found out
that's what they were doing on this
tanker no wonder he'd want to destroy
their Research In My Episode 1 video I
discussed how France may be ground zero
for the outbreak with Scientists here
responsible for the infection in the
final episode of the spin-off World
Beyond we also learned that the French
scientists may have been responsible for
the creation of variant zombies we've
already seen these acid blood burning
zombies known as bruyong who fling
themselves from buildings to get to
their meals no doubt there's some sort
of connection I'm curious if Janae may
have been one of those scientists and is
continuing their work the gang passes
through the famous per Lachey Cemetery
where famous people such as Moliere and
Jim Morrison are buried Jim Morrison was
the lead vocalist of the doors who sang
people are strange a French version of
which plays in the background of this
scene but it's Laurel here who talks
about a French Fable called death in The
Woodsman about a weary Woodsman who
wants to die but has a change of heart
and needs help carrying his burden it's
a metaphor for Daryl's Journey he's
going to survive he's going to need help
from others Daryl and the team meet up
with Valu the leader of the Network's
base of operation here in Paris but
unfortunately for Daryl there's no
working radio here either instead they
use carrier pigeons to communicate with
the nest and a response from them could
take upwards of a month that is if they
get a response at all the members here
all believe that LaRon is the second
coming of Christ or at least someone who
will deliver them from these trying
times he consoles a woman named Sonia
who lost her husband a few days ago a
woman falu says was unconsolable until
Laura arrived is it because Laurent
really has powers or do these people so
want to believe he's special they're
willing to suspend their disbelief Daryl
has lived up to his end of the bargain
he got them safely to Paris where the
others will take them the rest of the
way up to the nest now Isabel has to
live up to her end find a way for Daryl
to get back home fortunately there's an
underground group of traders who may be
able to help although they'll need
something in exchange this is how we end
up at Isabel's apartment a place we saw
last episode her hidden stash of the
fireplace is filled with drugs and
jewelry that they can exchange Daryl
also finds photos of Isabelle and her
ex-lover Quinn the man she left behind
at the gas station last episode we'll
get more into him in a bit it's funny
that the book this photo is found in is
from a collection of poems by Arthur
rimbo Who funny enough was said to be an
influence on Jim Morrison meanwhile
kotron has made his way to Janae we know
sometime has passed since episode 2
because his wounds have healed from his
first battle with Daryl kudwong believes
he knows where to find the American
having found the tape recorder and per
Jean's map he also has a personal drive
to kill Daryl believing it was Daryl who
killed his brother so Janae grants him
some men to track him down I also like
how her office has the famous LIberty
Leading the People painting ironic since
Janae seems to rule like an
authoritarian as Isabelle and Daryl make
their escape from The Walker infest a
department they stumble upon the little
girl from Isabelle's flashback I guess
she never made it back to her daddy but
the most WTF moment of the episode are
how these Walkers are so hell-bent on
their next meal that they fling
themselves out of the windows survive
and continue on their hunt for Daryl and
Isabelle these definitely aren't your
season one Walking Dead zombies Daryl
even uses one of the zombies acid blood
to melt the vines blocking their path
which I thought was pretty cool on their
way to the Traders Isabel gives larwal a
picture of Lily his mother this is the
first time he's ever seen what she looks
like now you can let me know in the
comments if I'm wrong but has Isabelle
even told Laurel that she's his aunt
anyways a bag of hazelnuts is the cost
to enter the Paris catacombs an
underground path filled with the skulls
of those who died during the black
plague as felu says Paris has survived
many apocalypses and they will survive
this one too they arrive at a nightclub
called Demi mold French for half world
this is a totally new environment for
Laurel and Sylvia who both have lived
sheltered lives at the Abbey the place
is adorned with relics from the old
world like a painting of water lilies by
Claude Monet Daryl says it reminds him
of home with water lilies being common
in the state of Georgia Isabelle has
brought the drugs and these guys want to
be paid just to lead them to a guy who
can give them a connection something
Daryl isn't too keen on that's when
Quinn steps in who runs this
establishment just to show you how
ruthless this guy is he slits a dude's
face for bringing in a weapon he's
definitely not a guy you want to mess
with Quinn takes Isabelle and Daryl to
the back room for a little catch-up
Quinn was the one who saved Isabelle's
life finding her in the bathtub when she
attempted suicide and Isabelle tells
Quinn that Laurel is Lily's child
Laurent meanwhile is given an Eiffel
Tower necklace by the club singer
something that reminds him of his mother
who loved the Eiffel Tower I'm wondering
if this necklace will come into play
later on now Quinn has these shocking
allegation that larvoir is his child
according to him he and Lily had a fling
and the child is his but I'm not too
certain I believe him in the flashback
in episode 2 he knows Lily is pregnant
where we're going it's secluded there's
no baby hospitals if he knew Lily was
pregnant here he'd know that he could
have been the father yet he tries to
convince Isabel to ditch her sister and
his own unborn child now Quinn says
Isabelle quote knows the terms if
they're to strike a deal to get Daryl on
a boat but it's a bit unclear what
exactly he wants is he wanting his son
Laurent or Isabel it felt unclear to me
so let me know what you thought in the
comments below regardless it's a deal
breaker for Daryl things get really
Rocky for Isabelle and Daryl going
forward but it's Laurel who gets caught
up in the middle it's like watching her
two parents fight Daryl has had enough
and decides to leave in the middle of
the night without even saying goodbye to
Laurel Daryl tells Isabelle that she
needs to stop lying to the child and
that he needs to know who he is only
then can he make up his own mind
meanwhile Daryl doesn't accept how
special the child is at least at this
point in time Daryl doesn't believe
Laurent is special and that people like
Isabel have put their hope in him as a
way to cope with how messed up the world
is because
men have arrived at the Demi mold in
search of the American Janae and Quinn
have a deal that the club is off limits
but Kajol is on a special Mission it's
heavily implied that Quinn leads these
men to fallu's Hideout where Daryl makes
his Escape through the rooftops of Paris
but before he goes he tells Isabel to
take Laurent and meet at her apartment
this is likely where they'll meet up
after being separated kodron pursues
Daryl and the two have their second big
fight with Daryl coming out on top once
again before being shot at by catron's
men and if things couldn't get any worse
Laurel seems to have disappeared and
Daryl falls through the roof of a
building so it looks like next episode
will have all three of our characters
split up I'm also curious where exactly
Daryl fell through so to look for Clues
we now get into the trailer sleuthing
section just a reminder I won't be going
over every shot just the ones that
pertain to new information we got this
episode flashbacks with Daryl on that
tanker are in store for us in the future
here's the explosion of that research
facility on that boat and I'm hoping we
find out just exactly what Jenny is
doing with these Undead and there also
seems to be a super fast zombie hot on
Daryl's tale Daryl fights what could be
Quinn back at the nightclub so he makes
his way back there somehow here's a shot
of Laurel outside the Eiffel Tower
making his wish in episode 3 come true
someday
I'll see the Eiffel Tower myself maybe
this is where he goes when he gets split
up in his separate shot we'll see
Isabelle and Daryl fighting underneath
the Eiffel Tower so it looks like all of
them have been reunited we'll even see a
shot of Daryl taking a boat along the
river sand I wonder if this is how
they'll make it out of this city the sun
after all connects to the hover which is
where Daryl wanted to go from this shot
here we see that Daryl and Laurel
eventually make it out of Paris with
Daryl giving him his brass knuckle knife
we'll also see this nighttime shot of
the crew making their way past some sort
of explosion in a smaller town but
expect kotron and his men to be in
Pursuit with Sylvie and Lauren
eventually getting captured I think
mostly Michelle here is the nest and
here we have Isabel and Laurent with
what may be soldiers in the background
what I found super interesting however
is that it looks like she's wearing
fancy earrings if they're getting ready
for some sort of War why would she be
wearing them Dara will also meet up with
Balu again who seems to have made it
unscathed from kudwal's Attack now this
shot is really cool check out the dart
in this zombies could this be another
one of janae's experiments from the
trailers it looks like we have at least
one more episode in Paris where Daryl
makes his way back to the nightclub
before ending up near the Eiffel Tower
and heading out of the city I'm really
enjoying the show so far and it's quite
possibly the best Walking Dead spin-off
yet thanks for watching and please be
sure to like And subscribe I plan on
covering every episode this season for
more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember
that's a bad
[Music]